so today session is on the globalization
secularization and transformation of
AIDS and we don't have Tony Blair with
us we don't have a resource additional
resource person with us so you kind of
stuck with me and with with Doug for
this for this course what I'll try to do
is maybe offer just a bit more extended
introductory comments on the topic and
then open it up for for discussion and
this may be opportunity also to kind of
range bit more broadly in terms of your
questions about faith than just the
topic of this of this session that is to
look back as well as maybe anticipate
the future and then I thought what I
might do in the second part of our of
this session is to take the question
that has surfaced very prominently and
very very quickly and very prominently
in the session which which we had one
session we had be Tony Blair and that is
the question of religious exclusivism
and the relationship between religious
exclusivism and kind of promotion of
pluralism as social value or as a
political project relationship between
exclusive religious claims and
pluralistic environments in which we
find ourselves and which globalization
processes are increasingly creating so I
have developed some comments on this it
was an essential element almost red
thread of discussions last year it
started I think was the first session
that was raised just like you did which
was which is which we should have then
built in reading about it and time for
reflection on this we didn't but as it
turns out we'll have probably thirty
five forty minutes
on that if that's what we that's as long
as you want to deal with a shoe so first
we talked to a bit about significance of
a that'll need to repeat any or any of
this and we are obviously dealing when
we're dealing with the question of
secularization and transformation of
faiths we are obviously dealing with the
future of faiths in the globalized world
and that future concerns questions of
religious adherence will fades do fates
continue to claim the hearts and minds
of people around the globe as much as
they did in the past for instance that's
a question that we need to answer and
the answer is yes in particular Islam
and Christianity Buddhism these three
faiths are growing in numerical terms in
relative and absolute terms as I said
previously will they do so in the future
well they're most likely we're good if
you extrapolate in the basis of data
that we have now it's likely it's going
to continue to be that way what will
those numbers be oh it's tough too tough
to say but it does look like an
immediate future at least the world's
gonna get to be a bit more for some of
you I should say even more religious
place then that it is right now now the
the connected question to this is not
just that of religious we're interested
not just that there are in religious
adherence we are also interested in role
of faith in public realm our faiths a
force that shapes realities beyond
people's private and narrowly communal
lives and we've seen previously
arguments which would suggest no faiths
are something very much private faiths
are if you won't even it'd be phenomenal
they don't shape anything they're shaped
by something conditioned by other things
but they themselves are some people
would even argue strongly causally inert
they don't do anything right they just
come to surface given certain conditions
right I'm not sure that's I'm pretty
sure that's not quite right but at least
that's one one of the possibilities and
if they are shaping realities beyond
private and narrowly communal lives of
people will they continue to do so in
the future and in what ways fates will
be significant right and then there's a
question also of the character of fates
how is the character where form that
fates take being shaped by globalization
processes and given that fates are being
shaped by globalization processes if
they indeed are how does how do the
influences go in complex ways so that's
roughly what we're going to be talking
about but first few comments on
secularization so and I want to give you
a few mention few aspects of
secularization often when we talk about
the secularization it ends up we end up
talking past each other because
secularization word secularization is
used in at least three distinct ways and
it's important to know what we are
dealing we are using the word when we
are using it so first sense of
secularization is differentiation of
secular spheres which is to say
differentiation of society and wind and
that society emancipation of say state
of economy of media broads spheres of
life from immediate or from even
immediate influence of religious
institutions and possibly even religious
norms now a verse of this is what
sociologists call privatization of
religion that is if religion is not
shaping how state is being run our
economy is being run well then religion
is increasingly has become a private
affair of individuals
so that's secularization in one sense is
differentiation right second sentence
which secularization is used is simply
decline of religious belief and practice
people are simply turning away from from
belief in God and people are turning
away from religious practices and there
may be discrepancies there right many
people can say that they believe in God
but they don't attend worship services
or if they attend worship services
doesn't matter very much matter in their
in their lives various ways in which
this decline of religious beliefs belief
and practice can be expressed and then
final sense is change in conditions of
belief and this has been introduced in a
book more more most compellingly in the
book this idea has been introduced and
what most compellingly in the book by
Charles Taylor a secular age it's a kind
of door stopper book it can inflict
serious damage if you wield it
in appropriate or inappropriate ways and
it's a long windy story in which Charles
Taylor tells but he's one of the the
great philosophers of our time and this
is really one of one of great books on
secularization issue but but his
question is how did we come to move away
from a society where belief in God was
unchallenged and unproblematic something
like fifteen hundred's right to a
society or to a cultural environment in
which faith is understood to be one
option among others and often an option
which is not the easiest one to embrace
so he's there as he's asking conditions
of belief and conditions of beliefs have
shifted and changed in such a way that
did you have to choose
that faith among multiplicity of options
rather than kind of slipping into it as
a state of normalcy in which society
operates now we will be interested
primarily in the first two aspects of
secularization in decline on individual
individual religious practice and belief
can be seen as a aspect of practice and
second in decline of cultural influence
of faiths though I don't think we should
bother too much with the question about
the future of religion and often
secularization is discussed in those
terms right and some people then expect
eventual demise of religion almost like
a as a matter of linear understanding of
history it's part and parcel of the
philosophy of history that religion
ought to or that religion will
experience demise or as kind of
conjectural extrapolation from data and
we're not so much interested in that not
just because this is not easy to answer
this question but because I think for
the purposes of this course it's not
necessary for us to answer this question
we're talking about next decades we're
not talking about ultimate future of
religion so let's now look at the
relationship between globalization and
secularization now one thing I think is
right to say is that globalization is
and entails modernization globalization
is fueled maybe primarily driven by
modern market system it's mediated and
helped by technological advancements
especially advancements in communication
but other also technological advances
and I think globalization is assuming
and
also reinforcing what sociologists call
individuation so to say that individual
is you've seen that I think burger
mentions that individual is taken out of
sort of traditional given identities and
thrown on his or her own resources to
make choices about life and
globalization also means rather
fast-paced fashioning and refashioning
of alternative almost global culture I
think some things happen in the global
level that's moving very fast in terms
of cultural change so all of these
elements I think are elements of
modernization but now the question is
whether modernization entails
secularization and authority one is the
same modernization to modernize is to
secularize and if modernization entails
secularization decline of religion in
society decline of religion in the minds
of individuals then obviously
globalization too will entail
secularization if religions survive then
they survive because they're holding
some onto something from the past either
because modernization hasn't progressed
far enough yet or because of social
inertia old resurgence of religion can
be kind of last gasp of religion before
its final demise law professor here for
whom I have great admiration it was my
friend Tony Kron Minh in conversations
with him he basically expressed this
this opinion what you see these
religious resurgence is a kind of last
gasp of religion before ha it gives out
its ghost
the other alternative is modernization
is not necessarily secularization which
means that there might be religious ways
to be modern embracing secularism is one
way to modernize embracing faith and
holding on to faith may be an
alternative way to modernize we'll
encounter this concept of alternative
modernities in the next session
especially the work of Jose Casanova who
will be our guest here and I would
encourage you to read carefully the text
assigned for the next week he stacks the
sign for next week I think that's one of
the best you know sociological analysis
of what's happening in the world of
religion today Charles Taylor himself is
a strong and sturdy both field mainly
philosophical advocate but also
sociological advocate of alternative
modernity
so if there are such alternative
modernist if there are religious ways to
modernize then obviously globalization
need not lead to secularization but as I
sometimes say globalization can be
played in multiple different registers
there are different religious registers
in which globalization can be played and
there's also secular presumably also
multiple secular registers in which gate
can be it can be played depending on the
particular culture in which through
which globalization processes refract
themselves
so but the question for us is not simply
whether it's possible for religion to
live together with advancing
globalization processes and my argument
would be that secularization thesis has
proven not to be correct at least for
now
but also what might be the impact of
globalization processes on the shape
which religions take and so I want to
talk about now about globalization's
impact on faith and there are few points
that I want to make here one of them
being globalization and the conditions
under which people embrace faith
globalization and the form which fates
take globalization and the modes of
transmission of faith and globalization
and the modes of religious influence
shaping the way religious influence
takes place okay so overarching
conditions under which people embrace
faith and often it may it boils down to
something like a malcontent with
globalization processes or with life in
general right all these religious people
actually there will be - I can give a
whole lecture about about the positive
experience of life in association with
embrace of religion but we'll keep that
maybe for another class another course
so for instance one can people
experience themselves as left out from
globalization's benefits and they're
seeking consolation in faith or possibly
seeking inspiration to change the rules
so as to attend to the losses of the
called losers a variation of that is
kind of experience of injustice as a
consequence of globalization and maybe
finding in faith assurance of future
justice or seeking motivation in faith
to struggle for justice you know this
idea of finding insurance in faith of
future justice this is very very
interesting how it emerged immediately
after the after World War two and among
some some very prominent Jewish thinkers
and the basic idea the basic intuition
was it somehow unacceptable that the
torturer would eternally triumph over
the victim some kind of sense of that
immense right defeat that Kalla cost was
and the immense wrong that it was
somehow crying for for justice a search
for justice max Horkheimer it's a very
interesting small book zine so connect
them guns under and the longing for a
radically different one right
is that good translation okay third
reason for a brace believing the
globalization undermines local cultures
and seeking affirmation of local
cultures through faith see they're very
easily in former Yugoslavia right not so
much
partly connected the globalization
process is how faith attached itself to
particular ethnic identities or
experiencing disorientation in
globalization this is kind of being
caught in the width of globalization can
feel like being in a swirling storm and
then seeking guidance uncertainty in
faith or sensing the meaninglessness of
the ends prevalent within globalization
processes and seeking meaning in faith
I'm not suggesting that all people do
that but some religious people that's
how the experience globalization and
therefore seek meaning anything or
believing the globalization driven by
market forces undermines human
flourishing by over privilege in say
consumerism and simply reinforcing
rather than shaping human desires
something on that zone and then seeking
alternative modes of human flourishing
in fates be globalization is shaping the
very form which faith takes it's
interesting phenomenon is
democratization of faiths so minutes
steady growth in the processes of
internal democratization of faith
subversion of authoritarian forms of
faith and even the forms of faith we'd
have a strong Authority structures
nonetheless incorporate in its own
internal internal structure democratic
elements non our territorial governments
and active participation especially
interesting here is inclusion women in
in in leadership roles and empowerment
of women in leadership roles then also
what's happening is that faiths tend to
be demurred from particular locales and
they tend to become global faiths or put
it differently it's only easily
transportable global faiths that seems
to be surviving best their best adapted
to globalism to the world's cotton
globalization processes somewhat in
tension with this is the idea of
rediscovery of culturally specific forms
of faith and you can see how
globalization processes might require
might threaten cultural identities and
fates may then take forms that are
culturally specific
and then interesting phenomenon and we
touched briefly on this is smorgasbord
religiosity especially find it in
Western culture or in kind of higher
echelons of global culture it's kind of
individually created faith tailored to
individual needs
you've got nuggets of wisdom from here
and there you combine those you are then
jubu right is that or whatever else
combination you can you can attach it's
probably that's not a that's not
exhaustive in description right of that
and there are other permutations and
combinations of fates and they're
tailor-made to a particular person and
they change also over time what how you
needs change so your religious
sensibilities and what you find useful
from different religious traditions so
that changes as well and they're
containing generally kind of no
overarching interpretation of of reality
they tend to be more kind of
spiritualities which energy eyes which
calm and soothe but rather than kind of
order the world is traditional spiritual
traditional faiths dead and they have
often relatively highly attenuated sense
of Ultima see it's not that you have
some sturdy divinity up there right but
rather you're finding the God in the
self that somehow is in each individual
again divinities tailor-made to the
South Sea globalization is shaping modes
of transmission for faith you know just
go back a little bit but the smorgasbord
religiosity it also turns faiths into
kind of a lifestyle choice that cannot
be contested by others in that which
takes the faith out of the domain of
truth claims which claims about what is
true and claims about what is good
traditional faiths they generally
understand themselves as containing
claims about the world that are
considered to be true and moral claims
also smorgasbord religiosity is a more
kind of a lifestyle religiosity there
are preferences in the ways in which we
seek to conduct our lives with kind of a
bit of religious aura to them that's one
way to put globalization in shaping
modes of transmission of faith
technologies of delivery faiths are as
present on internet and as they were
when radio was invented as there were
when TV was in his heyday if TV
evangelist notorious as they were were
ubiquitous I remember first time when I
came to this country and I came as a
student of theology you know very
religious person I was and I stayed with
it with a family afflicted channels and
and and came across this guy whose name
was Ernest Angley dressed in these
flamboyant flamboyant dress with the
toupee on the under his head walking in
this kind of half arrey arrey way and
then coming to people and taking ghosts
out of there evil spirits other ears and
I look my goodness where have I landed
this religiosity in America right Wow
everything is possible by the person you
realize that you know the america is the
land of extremes right and everything in
between also it's so technologies of
delivery right new technologies of
delivery which I think feeds also into
democratization of religions with very
little formal Authority or authority
that is earned in act right so the
authority of that is that is transmitted
through mass media often is precise with
such kind of authority especially
through internet right new missionary
movements from east to west
not just from west to east we used to
kind of thinking of Christianity as a
missionary religion goes from west to
east the missionary movements goes the
other way around Buddhism spread of
Buddhism foreign
this is a very good example of that or
the mission goes from non Wester to non
master country there's more missionary
activities of Christians between
non-western countries then between West
and the Western and then Peter Berger
has emphasized that and and also kind of
the response to Peter Berger in part by
conceived as a transmission of a in the
context of competitive religious
pluralism these religious pluralism
there's competition and that's how there
are those are the conditions for
transmission and I finally globalization
is shaping modes of religious influence
which is to say how globalization is
shaping the way in which fates engage
globalization processes themselves one
option is more traditional one religious
authority representing an institution
acting globally right for instance when
pope benedict xvi speaks that's how he
acts when dalai lama speaks that's
probably how he acts as a religious
authority but the other option is
increasingly increasingly prominent and
significant in formal religious
authority in the network of believers
and it's kind of shaping subcultural
movement of global dimensions bin Laden
he's a good example right or take it to
two Americans seen a most influential
religious figure in America is arguably
Rick Warren right but his authority is
clearly the authority of his books he
has no formal Authority at all
except maybe in his own Saddleback
Church and yet his authority stretches
not just in this country but around
around the globe that too is made
possible I think by modernization and
globalization processes
I'll stop here and opening it up for
comments questions on what we've been
discussing now or up also a bit broader
about religion or about this course okay